the first time you pick up the iPad pro
hears you're gonna say this thing is
huge and it is at twelve point nine
inches this is the biggest tablet Apple
has ever made it feels almost ridiculous
at first from a hardware perspective it
really does just feel like a huge iPad
at six point nine millimeters thick it's
actually thinner than the iPad air but
at 1.5 pounds it's like holding
one-and-a-half iPad Air's or two iPad
minis it's big you can hold it pretty
comfortably in two hands but if you hold
it in one you're either gonna drop it or
accidentally Club somebody in the head
with it it's also every bit as fast as
you'd expect an iPad to be the a9x
processor inside is super powerful and
even on a screen this high res I've
never seen a game or app so much as
stutter pro's display is twelve point
nine inches diagonal 2732 by 2048 those
numbers are huge but they really break
down to two things one you can just see
more of an app at once you can see the
interface and whatever you're working on
instead of having to tab through menus
and constantly go looking for things on
the other hand you can actually put two
apps side by side and they basically run
like full-sized iPad apps in portrait
mode you're not getting too small winnow
down browsers you're getting two
full-size apps that's how Apple thinks
you'll use this most and I think that's
exactly right that's the kind of thing
that makes the iPad pro feel much more
useful than other tablets even than
other iPads you can have your
spreadsheet on one side your research on
another and even float a Hulu window on
top and have it all work all at once
this extra size manifests itself in all
kinds of different ways for one thing
there are four speakers on the iPad one
on each corner and it will automatically
change depending on how you're using it
so you'll always get really loud stereo
sound
the keyboard also is the same size as a
laptop keyboard so you can almost touch
type you get used to it much faster than
you would a normal iPad these are small
things but they add up to something big
it's a tablet that you can use the way
you work without having to constantly
breathing and everything work by the way
is really what the iPad pro is about you
get the tablet itself starting at $799
with 32 gigs of storage it comes in gold
silver and Space Gray just like every
other Apple device were you're really
not getting the full iPad pro experience
until you also buy two accessories the
Apple pencil and the smart Keyboard the
pencil for its part is great it requires
some developer buy-in to really work
properly but once it does it's about the
most accurate and smooth this way you
can draw in your iPad if you want to
draw a doodle or just sketch this is
great but it's still just a stylus
neither the pencil nor the apps have the
same power or flexibility that you'd get
from something like Photoshop or
illustrator on the desktop right now the
iPad pro is a great accessory for a pro
not a tool that's gonna replace
everything you already have but for the
prosumer or just somebody who wants to
mess around the smart Keyboard on the
other hand isn't quite up to the Sam
standard it's built into a cover which
is neat and it'll just clip on and flip
over to protect the iPad pro screen or
you can unfold it and use it as a stand
for the keyword the mechanism itself is
a little bit awkward you kind of have to
swan dive it into place once you get it
there it's pretty sturdy and the
keyboard is actually really good the
problem is there's not enough you can do
with it if you're a person who loves
keyboard shortcuts or likes to navigate
around with your keyboard you're kind of
out of luck here there are a few you can
use command tab to switch between
Windows command shift age to go home
command space to do spotlight things
like that but there aren't keyword
shortcuts within most apps and even the
ones that do are very few the keyboard
is for typing nothing else the iPad pro
is not going to replace your laptop not
until you can organize all your windows
exactly the way you want to and not
until developer
decide that this thing is for capital W
work and start building their a sporting
in that sense Microsoft Surface pro is
actually closer to the market it has all
the features you want in a sort of
imperfect form factor this is
exceptional hardware but with a limited
feature set but whatever you decide to
use it for this is the most versatile
powerful capable iPad ever it's great
for watching movies playing games
browsing the web even doing some work
it's expensive and it's huge but it's
pretty great